[Music]
the batman is a complicated film with
several narrative threads unraveling at
the same time some of the story
revelations go by so quickly they can
leave audiences wondering about their
meaning keep watching to see the most
confusing moments in the batman explain
warning spoilers ahead
in interviews promoting the film star
robert pattinson talked about how
different reeve's vision for the source
material was i just knew there was
something radically different from
anything we've seen in my movies before
he felt that this new direction was
something viewers would find evident
from the film's shocking opening moments
he wasn't wrong either the movie opens
with a pov shot of someone peering
through a window of a large home where a
small child is playing with his father
but it's initially unclear what we're
looking at it's a jarring but
appropriate way for a film like this to
open it almost looks as if we're seeing
a young bruce wayne before that fateful
night that his parents were killed which
dovetails nicely with this child's grief
mirroring bruises instead it's a riddler
stalking his prey gotham's corrupt mayor
before going in for the kill the
patience to let the scene linger for as
long as it does really sets up the tone
and pace of the film
the first time we see mob boss carmine
falcone is through selena's eyes as
bruce monitors her infiltration of 44
below however the first time he and
bruce meet face to face is at the
mayor's funeral where falcone remarks
that bruce is the only person in the
city more inclusive than he is falcone
tells a brief story about how thomas
wayne once saved his life after the
mobster was shot he showed up on wayne's
doorstep with bruce's father operating
on falcone on the dining room table
while bruce watched from afar you don't
think that means something falcone asked
bruce bruce says it means his father
took the hippocratic oath when falcone
laughs at this bruce doesn't understand
what's so funny hippocratic sounds to
falcone like hypocrite even though bruce
thinks his father was a good man falcone
remembers the day thomas wayne asked him
to handle a problem for him it resulted
in a murder so he finds it hilarious
that bruce doesn't know the full scope
of his own father's complex morality
the revelation that falcone murdered
selena's mother is one of the film's
more nuanced reveals when selena tells
her tragic origin story to bruce she
mentions that after her mother was
murdered falcone let selena get
swallowed up by gotham's awful social
services system it's not until annika's
message is discovered on selena's
voicemail that we're able to put the
rest of the pieces together on the
recording we can hear that falcone is a
rat they've been searching for and that
he's the one who personally killed
annika even worse he did it with his
bare hands around her neck falcone's
penchant for strangling the women who
get in his way is confirmed even further
when he tries to kill selena trying to
choke her just like he did to her mother
once the riddler has been caught he is
revealed to be forensic accountant
edward nashton a traumatized orphan who
uncovered the rot at the core of the
gotham renewal fund it was a corruption
of the city that turned him into a
vengeful killer when rooting through his
apartment for more clues about his
motivations batman sees that he has one
last password-protected video to unlock
based on nashton's news clippings bruce
is concerned that the riddler has
figured out who the batman is
i think i'm his last target
when batman arrives at arkham nashton
tells a long story about how he hated
bruce wayne while growing up at an
orphanage to nashton it seemed that the
only sympathy gotham had for lost
children was given to a billionaire kid
who lived in a mansion it feels like
nashton is ramping up to reveal the
truth but it becomes clear that he's not
taunting bruce about knowing his true
identity
rather the riddler is lamenting the fact
that together the two of them took down
every one of his targets except wayne
nashton isn't talking to batman as an
adversary but as a partner after all
they're both vengeful angry men who
suffered in their youth and want to root
out corruption and see justice served
this moment and its implications are the
beginning of the end for bruce relying
entirely on fear and violence he sees
the limits of what he has done and worse
sees the evil his war on crime has
inadvertently inspired
another revelation takes place within
arkham's walls before the final credits
begin to roll as nashton has a meltdown
in his cell knowing that batman has
thwarted his plans a friendly cell
neighbor comforts him through their
interaction it becomes pretty clear that
the individual nashton is befriending is
supposed to be the joker however what's
confusing is barry kyogen's casting fans
assume that he'll be playing the joker
in some kind of post-credits scene this
scene taking place before the film's
actual closing moments is a bit of a
shock but largely because it begs the
question of how the joker ended up in
arkham is he already the joker did
batman catch him in a previous adventure
do we really need another live-action
joker so soon after joaquin phoenix's
oscar-winning turn with the character
only time will tell if he shows up in a
potential sequel
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one